What's your opinion on the keto mojo meter, which includes the GKI, ketones, and glucose. I'm not tracking anything currently.
I would think that that is not, you know, unless you're going to try to go into full keto.
Okay, so let's take a step back. So I currently don't have any patients right now that are doing full keto.
So there's a big difference between doing a keto-like diet and doing a full ketogenic diet.
So those who have played with doing a ketogenic diet actively and used a keto meter realize quite quickly that it's extremely difficult to truly get into and stay in ketosis.
It takes a lot of discipline and a lot of self-denial food because it's very difficult to get into and stay in a ketogenic state.
So by definition, a ketogenic state is where you are birding truly birding ketones and not birding glucose because you almost have them.
So is it good to get a meter to measure that? Yes, if you're going to do full true ketosis, you're trying to get into full ketosis, you're going to want to measure it.
So that you know you're in ketosis. I've had patients with brain cancer that have tried to get into full ketosis and maybe we're in ketosis for a day and their body slips back out. It's very, very difficult.
So there isn't a need for you to do that.
Therefore, there really is a need for you to measure that. Really, if you're trying to, if you're not dealing with a glioblastoma type brain cancer, there really isn't a need to get into ketosis.
Again, it's very difficult to get into it. It's very difficult to stay in and the diet is very difficult to stay on, even if you can't get into ketosis.
When you're doing a more modified ketogenic diet where you're just trying to stay, keep your glucose levels down, having a more simple glucometer with much less expensive test strips.
And a much less expensive glucometer where you could simply buy it at target and get the test strips who are pretty easy for pretty inexpensively and monitor your glucose.
Trying to get your glucose, your goal would be in the low 70s would be a perfect goal.
Good as I've been dealing with cancer patients for 30 years now, then eating zero sugar, zero carbs and still can't get their glucose below 90 some people.
Sometimes your cell membranes are damaged to the point where you're never going to get into it.
Now, if you're 21 years old and you want to go on a ketogenic diet for some reason because you're doing some sort of bodybuilding thing or whatever you're trying to do, it's much easier to get into ketosis.
I had a brain cancer patient that got into ketosis or I have several glioblastoma patients that got into ketosis and were able to stay in ketosis on and off for about three months and then finally gave up on the diet and are just on a more modified ketogenic diet because it's just too difficult to adhere to.
And it wasn't, they weren't able to stay in ketosis more than about a week at a time maximum, but they were in their 20s.
It's very difficult when you're beyond, you know, 30 years old to do that, almost impossible if you're older or less, you're so addicted to fitness that you, this is your complete lifestyle.
So is it important to get a meter like that and to measure ketoles? I don't think so.
The research that's out there for a cancer patient might say glioblastoma patient is that would be, you know, you're going to have just as much benefit as ketosis by just trying to get your glucose levels down and keep them down and staying away from as many carbs as possible.
Second thing is you don't ever want to go on a, you want to be careful, let's say, the degree of ketogenic like diet you're on, depending upon your current body weight.
Some people, because you're going to go on that type of diet, you're going to lose weight.
And one of the worst things that can take place for a person with a diagnosis of cancer is that they go into what's called kexia.
Meaning they start dropping pounds that they don't have to lose. And when you're losing weight that you don't have, you're not, you're not overweight.
That could be a greater danger than anything else. And we've, I've counseled people over the years that were in that state were very obsessed about their diet.
And I ended up pushing themselves into kexia that they couldn't get out of and ended up with their demise. So you did it to be very careful with that as well.
So all those things have to be taken into consideration.